all right if I'm going to start this
review off I'm gonna start it off by
being serious Here I am NOT going to
compare this movie or any other teen
romance movie to the T word anymore
things are given power because people
talk and think about them so if we stop
talking about it and thinking about it
and comparing things to it that
franchise will eventually just go away
like it should now let's review a movie
here
beautiful creatures so beautiful
creatures is a teen romance movie and
wish this was one chick she's a caster
or a witch she's about to turn 16 which
means she's going to either become good
or evil yeah no choice here she's either
gonna become a good chick or regular
checks teen romance movie I know what to
expect from these by now so let's just
go into it and see what happens yeah I
don't be honest with you the movie was
it was actually pretty enjoyable 5 to 10
minutes into this movie you're like okay
so this script actually has pretty
clever dialogue so in that you can enjoy
it then you meet Jeremy Irons who's
awesome he's like Count Dracula but
Jeremy Irons who probably didn't even
know he's being filmed so it's just all
badass I like his character a lot
because he's like this dark magic dude
who's choosing to not be evil so he's
kind of this in the middle character and
he can dabble in dark magic and be kind
of a dick sometimes
I love characters like that I'm like
you're the best of both worlds it's
everyone loves someone like that in the
movie that was about the first time in
this movie that it really clicked that I
am enjoying this movie is when the main
kid sits down and meets Jeremy Irons I
like the dialogue so far then something
happens where I was like that was
awesome then this scene ends and I was
like I dug that I like like that
that's what I liked about this movies it
wasn't too afraid to take it a little
farther than most teen romance movies
would take it yeah you're actually
rooting for these kids in this movie
really okay you're in love I get it I
want you to succeed I don't want the bad
magic to win because hey carries not
until later this year let's save the
meltdown for that movie until then
Jeremy Irons give us some cool lines
I mean Rossum was in the movie you know
I'm talking about this she's way hot in
this movie I mean Rossum disappeared for
a long time then she was on shameless I
haven't seen the show shameless I heard
it's good but I thought she was done
making movies and then shameless kind of
brought her career back and now she's in
this movie and she's good I'm not just
saying she's good because she's sexy as
hell which she is and I've always
thought Emmy Rossum was hopping in this
movie she's the hottest she has ever
been evil I love it oh thanks for
you know chicks are dating these really
dickbag kind of guys and you're like why
do you date dudes like that but I'll be
honest with you if some evil siren black
magic who looked and acted like
Emmy Rossum in this movie ever came out
to me and said hey let's give that a
shot I'd be like you sure I'm just a
dude don't hate me blend genetics some
of the CGI stuff looked fake in the
movie you're like yeah this movie did
come out in February I see that right
there with these special effects
some of the magic that happens it's
kind of psychological too and you kind
of like it like when he's going towards
the house and it just keeps repeating
he's on this like never-ending path I
thought dude Lost Woods and Zelda I'm
just glad that teen romance is kind of
finding its niche if it has one to find
which is like look we don't have to SAP
it up it will be a little sappy in that
teen romance kind of way but we can have
good actors and a script that's not
terribly shitty for a movie that is
enjoyable and we can make ourselves a
movie in a genre so the boyfriends don't
have to shoot themselves in the face
because they're like dude I'm really
watching this right now this had better
pay off like better pay off yeah that
was the look of expectation right there
the same it won't be like that in this
movie really for me what drag the movie
down it is a bit long it's not only long
but the movie takes a little while to
get going you're like I get it these two
are clicking and it's important to see
them actually build not love but like
they have to be interested in each other
and she has her walls up so she's gonna
be a bit standoffish cracking through
that takes an eon let alone a half an
hour of screen time this movie was a
solid 15 minutes shorter I'd be like
that's about where it needs to be
doesn't change the fact that I did enjoy
the performances in the movie Jeremy
Irons totally brings it in the movie
he's a badass character
emmy rossum sexiness is a total bonus in
a movie like this and the two main
characters actually did work well
together and I was rooting for him in
the movie so I'll actually say beautiful
creatures is a good time no alcohol
required so what are you gonna do for
Valentine's Day what are your plans
whether or not you have a date doesn't
matter you're probably doing something
today so whatever you're doing comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you